ce dont ont bénéficié les africains
américains lorsqu'ils sont venus en
france hexagonale
c'est de la puissance des états unis ça
c'est un paradoxe
ils ont pu bénéficier de la nationalité
américaine
et en cela ils étaient perçus comme des
êtres civilisés comme des êtres qui
faisait partie de la patrie qui avait
aidé la france et l'europe et le reste
de l'europe notamment au cours des deux
guerres mondiales c'est de ça dont ils
ont bénéficié au même moment dans
l'hexagone il y à d'autres populations
noires qui ne sont absolument pas traité
de la même façon et aujourd'hui encore
on est prompt en france en france
hexagonale du moins à citer donc les
personnes que vous avez mentionné que ce
soit joséphine baker que ce soit miles
davis que ce soit james baldwin qui est
très très à la mode actuellement richard
wright
on pourrait citer des artistes des
athlètes des militaires entre des
étudiants il ya plein de gens il ya je
sais pas moi
ana julia titre exemple qui a obtenu un
doctorat de la sorbonne qui a obtenu un
doctorat de la sorbonne au début du 20e
siècle oui elle existe mais quand on
parle de cooper on ne parle pas des
soeurs nardal par exemple qui était
également diplômée de la sorbonne et qui
venait de qui venait de la martinique
voilà donc on a je sais pas un
aveuglement auquel on s'accroche
un aveuglement qui sert une fonction à
mes yeux
et cet aveuglement il passe sous silence
toute une histoire nationale qu'on ne
veut pas regarder en face si on est prêt
à accepter l'existence structurelle du
racisme aux états unis on est d'emblée
dans la question de jeu c'est pas des
empires coloniaux des grandes
découvertes de l'institution de
l'esclavagé et toutes ces choses ont
également exister au sein de l'histoire
française
donc vraiment je trouve même cela
épuisant de devoir répéter ce genre de
platitudes en fait de platitudes en coin
la france se distinguerait des états
unis en termes d'histoire coloniale et
d'histoire esclavagiste la seule
différence entre les deux nations c'est
que là la population servile aux états
unis se trouvaient sur place et présente
depuis 1619 c'est à dire avant même
l'existence la création de cette nation
et d'état que sont devenus les étals et
les états unis
[Musique]